jacques bergier si vous aviez été le
rapporteur général du groupe 85 vers
quels secteurs auriez-vous mis l'accent
jeu rien c'était surtout ses lectrices
était l'âge de l'électricité n'est fait
que commencer jusqu'à présent nous ne
savions ni conserver l'électricité ni la
produire par des générateurs simple
léger et portatif
maintenant la situation ait changé
depuis 1962 nous avions une nouvelle
beauté au cadmium nickel
nous avons également les piles à
combustible et les piles solaires sec
effet que nous pouvons produire
l'électricité
elle a conservé comme nous voulons
monsieur bernard de la palme que pense
le reporter général du groupe 1985 de la
place de la technique et de la science
dans la société de 1985
je pense que cette place sera tout à
fait considérable dans la société d'une
fois 85 et d'une façon générale dans le
monde
je crois que de ce point de vue il est
extrêmement important que la france
tienne une place convenable dans ce
développement scientifique et technique
et je pense que il faut prévoir dès à
présent les moyens d'y parvenir
cette importance de la science et de la
technique sera probablement à des grands
éléments à des grands événements des 20
années à venir et
cela se sentira d'une part dans les
faits pratique si vous voulez en
particulier dans les modes de
consommation et dans le mode de vie des
gens qui pourront utiliser les produits
de ce développement scientifique et
technique
ils auront à leur disposition des
matériaux qui seront beaucoup plus
solide qui seront beaucoup plus joli que
je crois que ce sera un des gros
avantages du développement scientifique
de mettre à notre disposition pour des
prix moindre des choses qui seront plus
belle mais je pense que les gens auront
à leur disposition également un mode de
vie qui pourra être changé par ce
développement scientifique et technique
par exemple le mode de pensée des gens
pourraient être changées et ceci pourra
provenir du fait qu' il y aura beaucoup
plus de personnes mais beaucoup plus de
français
comment on peut dire qu'il est
souhaitable qu'il y en ait beaucoup plus
qu'ils se soient rompus aux disciplines
scientifiques
je crois que si actuellement il ya une
personne sur mille par exemple dans une
partie de l'existence est passé dans des
laboratoires dans une vingtaine d'années
on peut espérer qu'il y en aura dix sur
1000 c'est à dire dix fois plus je pense
que cette culture scientifique sera très
importante pour obtenir une mentalité
qui permettra de bien assumer les
changements considérables qui se
présenteront de plus en plus dans la
société de l'avenir
je crois que cette sorte de mobilité un
des lectures elle cette sorte de rigueur
intellectuelle sont des qualités qui
sont extrêmement nécessaire que
peut-être nous n'avons pas un degré
suffisant actuellement même par rapport
à certains d'autres peuples et je pense
que cet attachement que nous devrons
avoir aux disciplines scientifiques sera
très important de l'ensemble et bien et
bien et bien réellement ça me fait ça me
paraît trop sérieux et tellement ces
lieux que ce n'est probablement qu'une
espèce de rapport avec l'avenir
ça ne vous paraît pas sérieux de quelle
manière
ça me paraît trop sérieux ça mais ça me
paraît un peu analogue aux travaux de
certains sociologues qui essayait en
1923 de prévoir landes 1943 et bien
évidemment leurs travaux ne continue pas
du tout les fait qu'en juillet 1943 les
policiers avaient droit 125 g de
rutabaga l'avenir n'a pas été du tout ce
qu'il veut ce qu'il prévoyait
de même je pense que les travaux du
groupe 85 sont un prolongement sens et
raisonnable logique de l'année 1965 et
que c'est pour ça il ne se réaliseront
absolument pas je pense que l'avenir de
1985 sera absolument différent de ce
qu'ils imaginent
mais pensez vous que la démarche
prospective soit on cause je pense c'est
la démarche prospective qui est en cause
parce qu'elle n'est pas assez folle un
moment donné ont présenté un des grands
physiciens nucléaires le maître de
l'atome niaise bourg une nouvelle
théorie physique
il disait ce n'est que leur a
certainement pas parce que c'est une
tuerie qui n'est pas assez folle eh bien
je pense que les travaux du groupe eut
lieu de 185 métiers ne sont pas ces fous
qu'ils ne tiennent que dit ou des sacs
de ces caporal expiration
parce qu'ils nous tiennent absolument
aucun compte de ce qu'apportera
l'exploration de l'espace intérieur de
la psychologie des profondeurs de
parapsychologie derrière des recherches
de recherche la psycho chine y est ré
penser d'une manière générale que cet
avenir qui est en quelque sorte
présupposés par ces gens qui ont
réfléchi pendant plus d'un an
le commissariat général du plan c'est à
venir est trop raisonnable
je pense que je pense que la re que ce
que c'était que c'est un avenir beaucoup
trop raisonnable
je pense que c'est les gens je pense que
pour c'était notre exemple et nièces et
laisser les gens de venir comme pouvait
extrapoler ce sombre si on pouvait
sonner son nom avait étudié leur
business en la progression des lots de
la forme des fous et à cheval et des
fiacres alors n'aurait conclu qu étant
donné l'expansion démographique
étant donné l'expansion économique est
bien d'ordre dans 20 ans la vente des
fiac et la bande des fouets à cheval
aurait augmenté dans une proportion de
48 86 % jeune bergère raison à se
projeter dans l'avenir on court en effet
quelques risques le risque d'extrapoler
à tord et à travers par exemple mais il
faut se projeter dans l'avenir
si la france veut n'être pas noyé dans
le marché commun
si elle veut que ce n'est que nos mines
soit pas colonisé de façon presque
invisible par celle des états unis
si elle veut que ses habitants n'est pas
seulement dans 20 ans un niveau de vie
plus confortable mais aussi un mode de
vie qui ne soit pas inhumé elle doit se
projeter dans l'avenir
mais elle doit le faire en se souciant
d'un problème celui des fins qui doivent
être assignée au progrès oui dans ce
livre on al'impression ok peut-être
superficielle de penser que l'homme est
définie par trois terme la production la
consommation et les loisirs
je trouve que c'est insuffisant selon le
vocabulaire que l'on emploie pour
définir l'esprit ou larmes de l'homme et
qu'il manque quelque chose
je pense d'ailleurs à ce mot loisirs qui
est aussi par certains côtés un peu
inquiétant dans un passage de ce livre
où on s'inquiète beaucoup de loisirs de
l'homme et d'un phénomène dont je
parlerai qu'il fallait mettre de la
nature
on nous propose créer ou de localiser de
grands déserts et j'imagine en effet le
19 décembre où le 20 avril les hommes se
précipitant par millions dans les
déserts pour affronter la nature ou pour
la regarder
ce n'est pas exactement ce que nous
souhaitons et cela nous amène à demander
des choses plus positives
je crois que il faut d'abord demander
exiger que l'homme ne perdent pas le
contact avec la nature et quand je parle
du contact je ne parle pas du contact
collectif
je parle du contact individuel la nature
est une des sources très grand de
l'enseignement et développement de
l'homme individuelle et quand il aura
perdu son contact avec la nature il aura
perdu une grande part de lui-même il ya
une autre chose que l'on devrait
s'efforcer l'examiner aussi un peu à
titre individuel c'est que l'homme de
perdre le perde pas ses mains et là la
main n'est pas une sauce collectif c'est
vraiment une chose individuel c'est une
des formes les plus grandes découvertes
les enseignements et des joies de
l'homme l'a d'ailleurs on a parlé
souvent du travail sont distinguer deux
choses qui sont capitales le travail
pratique productif nécessaire qui était
évoqué d'ailleurs d'une manière un peu
politique dans ce livre gagné s'agit
pour la perdre et on ne parle pas
beaucoup du travail pour le
développement propre de l'homme
et ce travail pour le développement
propre de l'homme se trouve dans sa main
on constate par exemple un phénomène
notre monde moderne qui s'accélérera
c'est la disparition de l'artisanat est
bien l'homme doit pouvoir être par
l'enseignement sont propres artisans et
faire face à des problèmes que
l'industrie et ses formes nouvelles
la bande pas vous savez très bien que
maintenant il est presque impossible de
trouver quelqu'un pour changer un bouton
électricité un bouton de porte réparer
faire une petite réparation de moteurs
sur le champ et il faut donc que la
culture de l'homme le conduisent à être
son propre artisans et qu'il est ce
contact avec un travail qui n'est pas
proprement productif mais qui est une
forme extraordinaire aussi de loisirs
alors les loisirs télé comme manger les
loisirs très organisé nous avons vu des
pays qui ont leur fait l'expérience et
l'homme on évite la c'est donc garder la
nature à titre individuel garder les
mains à titre individuel et puis j'ai
dit j'irai même ne peut être un peu plus
loin garder les pieds
je ne sais pas peut-être que nous aurons
un jour comme le pensaient certains
savants de mes amis des hommes qui pour
aller dans la lune où l'on venus sable
iront à ne plus avoir le pied elle pu
voir la main mais je crois que ce n'est
pas pour 1985 encore heureusement est
alors ses pieds c'est une chose qui est
une des
gérard et rémy que pensez vous de ces
livres que vous êtes en train de
regarder et bien vissé la solution de
l'avenir c'est très réel
c'est mon but c'est très vivant les
cours seront êtres vivants avec
illustrée du contour pareil alors vous
pensez que pour l'avenir ce serait très
bien
oui nous ils sont très durs alors et
midi nous comment on peut utiliser les
photos de ce livre montre nous comment
on peut faire
alors ça
si lidl de marloux trouvait à carros
aujourd'hui au musée durs sas et le
palais des princes
le cos qui s'élève sur une colline ce
qu'il faut situer sur la rigoureuse du
gain keira tous leurs achats que vu vous
avez l'explication sur le livre ni ceux
des récents l'espace je pense que nous
faisons nôtre et mon voyage en restant
chez soi
les statuettes une figurine de faïence
au de 266 mais ce qui a été trouvé dans
le cimetière central du palais des
glaces ans
gérard est ce que vous avez dans le nez
moi je
des fusées l'explication donnée vous
pouvez nous a montré quelques-unes
ceci j'ai d'une fusée mais à feu
qu'elles s'appellent atlas propose d'une
capsule mercury aucune place à l'estomac
gary cooper
c'est une planète qui s'appelle la terre
notons plein inventaire telle qu'on la
voit du ou la satellite artificiel
vous avez de plus de relief alors en
regardant ces images en couleur oui on
comprend mieux ailleurs et ce sont deux
très jolies photos
c'est l'épreuve du tapis rouge il ne
s'agit pas d'une une phase particulière
de lydia de l'entraînement des
cosmonautes moment terre l'une des
exigences de la gloire bah oui ceux ci
après vous voyez la chine stations de
surveillance de la fusée eric le coz
l'autre didier dans l'espace et vont
être seul alors vous pensez que ce moyen
d'expression facilitera vos cours et que
vous aurez plus de facilité ce sera
moins fastidieux pour apprendre vole
sans ambition j'ai l'impression que ça
nous marquerait l'une soit ce soit ceux
des cours unis vont nous ne serions plus
frappé
lundi
fiction et si nous pouvions voir
quelques paysages de graisse sont
montrés
à
ce câble qui vous apporte 40
possibilités de choix domicile est je
crois la révolution de l'avenir le la
manière dont on peut s'en servir
être au fond de mettre la disposition
des individus la possibilité de choisir
eux-mêmes les images et les sons qui
désirent recevoir non seulement pour
leur distraction non seulement pour leur
éducation mais encore pour tous les
actes pratique de la vie
j'ai déjà un fait la télévision peut
apporter l'enseignement programmé à
domicile
demain elle offrira sur un écran de
taille illimitée des programmes choisis
à la carte
même seul chez soir on pourra préférer
les jeux de société au jeu de patience
en prenant comme partenaire soit un ami
lointain soit un ordinateur
la télévision sera le super catalogue
des ventes par correspondance
mieux encore le simple geste d'un doigt
sur un bouton fera connaître le choix de
la cliente et tiendra lieu de commandes
journaux lettres télégrammes
contravention apparaîtront ainsi sans
retint les textes pourront à volonté
être reproduction papier pour être
consultés et conserver
en fait on peut se demander si le mot
télévision est bien celui qui correspond
à cette circulation histoire d'une ère
nouvelle libre les images et des sons
que l'on peut envisager pour l'avenir
télévision pour nous est associé à une
idée d'abord de radiodiffusion
transmission par honte télévision aussi
à implique une certaine passivité
tout ce que vous voyez au contraire
arrivée par le canal de ce câble
implique une participation active de
chacun
au fond il on trouve pas de mots
audiovisuel matériel aux dubiez ne
marche pas j'attends que des
professionnels de la lande trouva un mot
mais à mon avis c'est de ce mot nouveau
qui définira très bien les possibilités
extraordinaires de circulation des
images et des sons
vous ne connaissez pas elle est pourtant
en circulation depuis 1942 sell-off
électrique de paul à reims au lardin se
perdent et locomotrice bb et cc de la
sncf pour les villes certainement que la
la traction électrique doit son avantage
à son comment sa propreté à son côté
pratique puisque tous les éléments tous
les tous les instruments ménagers sont
aujourd'hui électrique une voiture peut
être considérée comme également un
instrument ménagers si cette voiture
électrique et et comme on peut le
supposer une voitures de petits gabarits
tu quand je crois qu'on n'a pas envisagé
de certaines normes véhicule et elle
aura un autre avantage c'est d'amener
dans la circulation des petits véhicules
d'un gabarit tu plus facile à garer à
ranger et que bien entendu comme
l'espace à paris et très hélas très
limités comme nous comptons qu'il ya à
peu près 240 mille places tout le long
de la voirie parisienne
il est vrai que si vous amenez une
voiture qui fait la moitié de cette de
l'espace normal des voitures actuelles
on pourra ranger deux fois plus non moi
je suis tout à fait d'accord
oui ça sera bon pour le maintien la
voiture électrique faudrait qu'elle soit
d'un maniement assez simple
les débuts de la voiture électrique
coïncident avec ceux de l'histoire
automobile
la première fut l'agent tôt en 1894
il y eut aussi des modèles spéciaux
comme celui du grand duc nicolas puis
des véhicules utilitaires des auto
écoles celle des chauffeurs de taxis
parisiens autres et bien entendu il
arrivait parfois des accidents mais de
toutes ces voitures la plus luxueuse
suis sans doute la criée guerre rolls
royce des automobiles électriques et
première traction avant de l'histoire de
l'automobile
la compétition à son tour sans parade
d'électricité avec jean tôt encore il ya
une bataille infernale à la fin du 19e
siècle pour le record du monde de
vitesse
il se battait régulièrement ils se sont
battus je crois le record quatre fois en
en quelques mois j'ai mangé nazis a
triomphé en effet arraché en 1899 le
coin belge camille jenatzy au volant de
la jamais contente s'adjuger le record
du monde de vitesse avec 105 kilomètres
heure ça a duré jusqu'à corps ça dure
jusqu'en 1904 1905
pourquoi s'arrêter il y avait plusieurs
raisons mais croit que la principale il
faut faire appel à freud s'était pas
viril
le possesseur d'une nature en 1900 c'est
même que celui qui aujourd'hui une
ferrari une maserati lamborghini non une
voiture c'était viril c'était pour se
déplacer c'était pour plaire votre
électrique c'était silencieux
c'était tranquille alors qu'une voiture
à essence a fait du bruit ça sentait
mauvais et puis là le mal mettez en
route à la manivelle
alors voilà je crois c'est ça la vérité
en 1940 la guerre les restrictions plus
d'essence des voitures électriques
réapparaissent paya guerre équipe des
châssis licorne peugeot sort la voiture
légère de ville l'ingénieur grégoire lui
construit des véhicules de records j'ai
donc fait cette voiture leur corps est
aux musées du mans 450 kg de poids de
voitures à vide ce qui est faible et
tenez vous bien 750 kg d'accumulateurs
là dessus
la performance officielle était la
suivante je suis partie un matin de
paris avec monsieur del perú contrôleurs
de ter club de france et j'ai été plus
loin que tour d'une seule traite j'ai
fait 250 km contrôler officiellement à
43,2 moyenne ce qui n'avait jamais été
fait et ce qui n'a toujours jamais été
égalée s'en charger les actuels s'en
charger les équipes bien entendu après
la guerre la traction électrique est
abandonnée sauf en grande-bretagne où il
roule actuellement 55 mille véhicules
électriques principalement utilisé pour
le service domestique
une fois le courrier distribué le pain
et le lait livré à domicile et véhicules
reviennent à leur tour s'abreuver de
courant ils sont ainsi des centaines
assurer leurs services quotidiens dans
les grandes villes britanniques où ils
constituent des éléments indispensables
au confort et à la commodité de la vie
ménagères
cette même commodités l'usagé anglais la
fin des différents prototypes qui lui
sont actuellement proposées
mention particulière pour la forte comme
état dont le nom signifie navette
c'est presque la voiture urbaine idéal
longueur de mettre 20 capacité deux
adultes et deux enfants vitesse moyenne
60 kilomètres/heure rayon d'action 100
km
aujourd'hui en france la traction
électrique se limite pratiquement à ces
autocars à double commande que l'on peut
emprunter sur les aéroport de marignane
où d'orly
mais les grands constructeurs
s'intéressent au problème renault
s'intéresse depuis longtemps aux
véhicules électriques mais plus
particulièrement depuis trois ou quatre
ans sont apparus des piles à combustible
fonctionnant à basse température est
susceptible d'être montés à bord de
véhicules
notre accord avec la groupement
comprenant la csf l'iafp et le carbone
lorraine a pour objet l'étude d'une
telle ville d'une puissance de 24 kg
watts dans l'immédiat comme il s'agit de
mettre au point des techniques nouvelles
nous allons réaliser un véhicule est à
fait qui nous permettra lorsque nous
maîtriserons les techniques de pouvoir
monter soit allée puissance plus élevée
éventuellement pour des véhicules du
type grands routiers ou bien au
contraire de redescendre à des véhicules
plus petits type urbain
la voiture électrique surtout avec la
formule de la pile à combustible nous
intéresse nous croyons que c'est une des
formules possibles de l'avenir dans la
mesure où nous croyons que c'est une
formule possible de l'avenir notre
service de recherche le bureau d'études
y travaillent dans la mesure où le
bureau d'études y travaillent
je ne peux pas vous en parler les
automobiles peugeot et alstom ont signé
un contrat en 1967 pour l'étude de la
réalisation de piles à combustible 7
ce contrat vise essentiellement les
piles à combustible qui pourrait faire
l'objet d'une adaptation sur des
véhicules à propulsion électrique
les piles à combustible elles sont
étudiées dans ce laboratoire où pour la
première foi pénètrent des caméras de
télévision
les éléments ultra léger qui les
constituent sont destinés à remplacer
les accus traditionnels dont le poids et
l'encombrement ont entravé jusqu'ici le
développement des voitures électriques
une pile à combustible est un dispositif
nouveau et on peut dire révolutionnaire
il permet de transformer directement
l'énergie chimique des combustibles en
énergie électrique
une pile vous voyez est alimentée
continuellement par les réservoirs des
combustibles elle fonctions tant que le
reste on qu'il y à du combustible dans
le réservoir pour la propulsion
d'automobiles nous pensons que le
combustible intéressant et le méthanol
qui au fond n'est autre que l'alcool à
brûler les avantages de la file est
construit les avantages de la
combustible sont très nombreux tout
d'abord on peut remarquer que c'est des
dispositifs stati cet allié une bouche
pas il n'ya pas de parti qui vibre qui
tourne
par conséquent il ne provoque pas de
bruit nos piles qui sont dues aux
conceptions originales de monsieur marc
chasse qui sont extrêmement légère et
compacte ne semble de très loin en
avance par rapport ni aux autres
constructeurs sur le plan mondial vous
voyez une telle pub elle fait appeler
fait plaisir kilowatts
elle pèse quelques kilos à peine c'est
donc extrêmement léger et très compacte
si vous la comparez à la fois une
impuissance à un accumulateur intel
accumulateurs pèsera à peu près 200 210
l'on peut même pas le sauver vous voyez
la différence est énorme
c'est un des avants grand avantage de
nos piles quel serait le volume d'une
pile pour une 6 chevaux actuelle est
bien qu'on siffle actuel saad et si
chaud fiscaux autrement dit une
trentaine de chevaux réel
nous comptons qu'il faudrait une pile
qui 2 qui pésent et environ 40 à 50 kg
elle est par conséquent très compétitive
par rapport au poids à l'encombrement
des moteurs à explosion souvent c'est
que cette propulsion par piles à
combustible se ferait si rapidement
je pense qu'elle peut se faire
rapidement puisque comme vous le savez
des véhicules expérimentaux puis
combustible existe déjà un peu partout
dans le monde mais je pense également
qu'il faut distinguer véhicules
expérimentaux et véhicules mises à
disposition du public pour ce qui est
des véhicules mis à la disposition du
public je ne pense pas que des véhicules
à pile à combustible seront vraiment
vendu avant 1975
pour l'heure chacun de nous connaît ses
longues files de voitures trop grande
ovide inapproprié au trafic urbain
c'est l'univers concentrationnaire de
l'automobiliste où s'échangent insulté
coupe ou parfois l'énervement conduit
jusqu'au meurtre
pourtant sans trop rêver on peut espérer
que demain la voiture électrique à
panther à un remède à tout cela
fabriqué à une grande échelle elle
pourrait être la seconde voiture idéale
une voiture dont il ne serait pas
nécessaire d'être propriétaire dans des
stations services spécialisés les
changes de véhicules se ferait
instantanément sur simple présentation
d'une carte d'abonnement
véhicule urbain dans un proche avenir
rien n'empêche de penser que la voiture
électrique pourra devenir une grande
routière
les français ont une vision à la fois
optimiste et raisonnable de l'an 2000
d'une manière générale ils pensent que
le pouvoir de la science et de la
technique seront considérables
les plus grands progrès souhaités sont
dans l'ordre la guérison du cancer
la disparition de la guerre la
disparition du chômage possible ou
impossible en l'an 2000 voici quels sont
certains espoirs où certaines craintes
de l'homme de la rue dans le domaine de
la santé
84 % des gens interrogés pensent que le
cancer pourra être guéri en l'an 2000
mais 78% pensent qu'il y aura davantage
de malades mentaux
au chapitre des voyages soixante huit
pour cent des français estiment qu'il
sera possible d'effectuer en l'an 2000
le voyage paris new york en une heure
67% pensent qu'il y aura en france dix
mille kilomètres d'autoroutes 64%
pensent que les douanes et les
passeports seront supprimés mais 29%
seulement pense que l'on pourra aller
régulièrement dans la lune dans le
domaine du logement
75 % des gens interrogés pensent que les
grandes villes seront couvertes de
gratte ciel mais 61% estiment que la
majorité des habitants des villes aura
une maison de campagne
la pluie à volonté l'utilisation
courante d'eau de mer dessalée sont
également indiquées comme étant
possibles en l'an 2000
parmi les professions qui seront en
accroissement d'après les français il y
aura surtout les professeurs les
médecins mais aussi les policiers et les
fonctionnaires
enfin dernier exemple de ce sondage très
complet à la question pensez vous que
l'europe ne formera plus qu'un seul pays
en l'an 2000 les français se partage par
moitié mais ils sont plus optimiste à ce
sujet que la plupart des étrangers